[Music]
these are the best s-log picture profile
settings it's called portrait 800 it's
part of my sony film simulation recipes
and today i will show you exactly how to
color grade it in under one minute
this is a quick color grading tutorial
and presentation of the best s-log
picture profile also called portrait
800. this is a profile that i've been
working on since my first sony film
simulation recipes which is about two
years now and after a lot of shooting
testing and comparing different gammas
color modes and settings i came to the
conclusion that if you're looking for
great color right out of camera this is
the best picture profile for s-log on
any sony camera
this profile will give you better color
rendition less noise artifacts and
amazing skin tones you can find it on my
website it's part of my sony film
simulation plan which costs only five
dollars per year and if you ask me it's
basically free because it includes all
updated 20 sony film simulation recipes
together with all the color filter
settings that will give you the film
look
these are some shots from the last video
this is the before and this is after as
you can see it looks amazing and has
really natural colors even though being
in nature we were surrounded by a lot of
green hues you can notice how the
profile is rendering lovely skin tones
and the green cast is barely noticeable
you can find the settings to the updated
profile and all my other film simulation
settings on my website link in
description down below
this is how the footage looks without
the camera it has gorgeous colors and if
you're overexposed and right at about
1.5 or 1.7 you will get the most out of
this profile with least amount of noise
if you ask me in many cases it's good to
go as it is the only thing they like to
do is bring down the shadows just a
little bit to hide more of the noise
located in the darker areas
maybe decrease the saturation and
increase the contrast just a bit to put
focus on the right things and let your
eyes fall where it's supposed to you can
do that by activating the splines in the
curves panel
and then in the left corner select the
black point and bring it down
also bring down the saturation to about
35 to give it a fitted look this is how
you make a basic grade simple and easy
the profile is so good it doesn't need
much post-processing to look natural and
with pleasing colors
now let me show you how you can get the
same look as in the original video to
grade this footage is the creative film
power grade you can find the link in the
description down below
in the creative film power grade you can
choose from 54 classic film color
presets 35 film contrast gammas and
multiple halation effects and afterwards
you can export them as your own custom
lots so let me show you how to use it
i'll use the note 3 from the film pack
to make it easier
apply contrast of your choice and then
manually adjust it to your liking
next browse through all the classic film
colors and apply one
one of my favorites is the scenic color
the name is an image the first
successful color motion picture process
which was called cinema color
let me know in the comments if you want
to find out more about that
now let's adjust the halation
there's something i forgot to mention in
my last video the creative film power
grade includes two types of hilation
effects the davinci resolve plugin which
has my custom settings installed and
which is included in the note 3 by
default but this effect will work only
if you have a davinci resolve license
but don't sweat it for those who don't
have a license for davinci resolve i
included manual revolution effect
it's in the resolution folder and if you
followed my previous tutorial on how
powerful davinci resolve power grades
are you already have them imported if
not go check that video to learn how to
use power grades step by step from
scratch
you drag and drop the halation effect on
the node and you can see the effect is
already showing now how to edit the
intensity of the effect right click on
the node enter the compound node a
compound node is like a nest where you
group a node tree to make it tidier and
simplify the structure enter the
compound node and you will see we have a
couple nodes
check for the color space transform node
here you set the input gamma for meets
s-log 2 and the output set it to linear
be sure to check the settings to be the
same otherwise it's not going to work
then go to the second color space
transform choose input gamma linear and
output gamma whatever you have shot it
rec 709 log
minus s log 2 so i'll put s log 2 again
now let's go to the layer node which is
this one and yours might look a little
bit different i have updated the red
holution effect but that's not a problem
to be sure is the same let's reset it
and remake it from scratch this activate
the splines
now select the white point and drag it
down completely
make a note in the middle of the spline
simply by pressing and now drag the
white point back let's say 25 of the way
go into the blur panel and unlink the
colors so you can blur out the reds
now drag the red all the way up and wait
a second to assess if it's too much you
can also drag green and blue to give a
different hue variation to the hilation
and there you have it this is how i
graded the footage and i think the
creative film power grades made it so
much easier with all the presets i color
graded the footage in a couple of
minutes a job that could have taken me a
lot longer if you want to find out more
about color grading i invite you to my
online course which will help you easily
understand color grading in a short
period of time it's a group class which
i'll be holding next month in this
course i will guide you in the process
of creating your own footage and explain
different techniques that will make the
whole process easier to grasp all the
lots will be provided at the end of the
course for free so go check it out save
your spot it's going to be fun link in
description also go check out my sony
film simulations if you're interested in
that hope this helped clear out some
questions let me know in the comments
what you'd like to see next till then
have fun and stay curious see ya
[Music]
you